let's just go get it over
with no he already knows what's going on
just let's go get it over with come on
an Ohio woman is arrested on charges of
involuntary manslaughter and connection
to a deadly house fire the victim was
her own 8-year-old son police arrested
Dakota Jones on December 12th on charges
of involuntary manslaughter and
endangering children body cam video
captures police arresting Jones as she
seems un surprised authorities are at
her home yeah we're good
okay go ahead secret
indictment turn around for me huh just
turn around for me okay thank
youg be
okay hold on to
this um I'm going to use it to call my
my mother and stuff and my lawyer too so
wait it'll go it'll go the pockets on
these my pockets okay I got
check after Jones's flippant remark the
arresting officer then searches her to
make sure she doesn't have any weapons
before she's carded off to the back of a
police cruiser let's just go get it over
with no he already knows what's going on
just let's go get it over with come on
I'm this what pointed that
way you want your seat Bel on just
go she was then hauled off to the local
jail officials say Jones's 8-year-old
son Wyatt duett died in a house fire on
June 7th of last year year her
10-year-old stepson was able to escape
the Flames but sustained injuries from
that deadly Inferno police say Jones
left the two boys alone while she ran to
the bank and when she returned home she
saw the house was on fire the State Fire
Marshal's Office reportedly was able to
determine the cause of the fire was due
to poorly discarded smoking material
that was left out and said that police
believed Jones was responsible calling
the fire a tragic accident Jones later
appeared inside an Ohio courtroom where
a judge ordered she be held on a $50,000
Bond she pleaded not guilty to the
charges next we had about 2 hours south
of Norwalk to Franklin County Ohio where
body camera footage captures the moments
five teenagers LED police on a
high-speed chase in a stolen car then
later crashing it which resulted in the
death of a father of two the tragic
incident happened on November 25th
according to authorities Franklin County
sheriff's deputies received a call about
a stolen Kia a deputy later spotted the
stolen vehicle and attempted to pull it
over but the teen started speeding
away s Bridge speed
66 traffic's lighted condition is clear
dry
westbound pressure
ground
then less than a minute later the stolen
Kia runs a stop sign crashing into
another vehicle as one of the passengers
attempts to
[Music]
flee but a deputy's body cam video
captures the passenger being quickly
apprehended by authorities get on ground
right now get down on the
ground me put your hand behind your back
I'm not resisting nothing I'm sorry yeah
shut up
bro one cust over
here you got any weapons on you no
sir
I got nothing I can St T years in
another deputy's body cam video captures
the aftermath of what would turn out to
be a deadly
crash get out the ground get out the
ground get off the ground get off the
ground right now get off the ground okay
face
[Applause]
down
I'm going get him here a second I don't
know put your hands body
back can you un my hoodie
nope stay right there in the driver
seat
oh
hey after two of the teens are cuffed
the deputy then notices the gry Honda
which is an utter wreckage as well as
completely total but more devastating a
person was left trapped
inside hey you got your break out tool
you got your tool for that one you got
somebody in there yeah the deputy then
turns his attention to the driver of the
stolen Kia due to the vehicle's airbags
being deployed the deputy then carves
out a hole to get the teen driver out of
the car
step
out step out step
out get out of the car cooling on my
shirt just watch him watch
him the video then shows the deputies
using life-saving measures including the
jaws of life to rescue the driver of the
Honda hey boss can you hear me can you
hear
me
yeah i' already got that
off try the back door
unlock all right I don't know it was
later revealed the Honda was driven by a
local father of two 36-year-old Matthew
Moshi who died later from injury
sustained in the deadly crash sa a Chase
yeah this car was stolen we were West
yeah westbound here on Beacon Hill and
it just shot through the uh stop
sign all these people over here do you
know anything about I don't have no idea
they might be the owners of this car I
don't know yeah it's I cut myself
probably getting them
out 36
36 another
distri where's where's
the I don't know where they're all
at there were four total I
think I saw two on the ground pulled up
there's one down there and there's one
in the car SE yes this guy
was see I got one in T I don't know if
anyone's in
33 the driver of the stolen Kia was
identified as a 15-year-old whose name
was been withheld he faces a charge of
receiving stolen property it's unclear
if prosecutors have upgraded his charges
or if he'll be tried as an adult okay we
want to thank Morgan and Morgan for
sponsoring this body cam video I mean I
think it's pretty clear from the body
cams that we cover that it's not always
safe out there when you're hurt it can
be confusing it can be scary you don't
really know where to turn well Morgan
and Morgan is actually the largest
injury law firm in America America in a
time when you already have so much to
think about they're going to make it
super easy for you they have completely
modernized the process because you
submit your claim you sign contracts you
upload documents you talk to your whole
legal Team all on your phone that's it
an attorney is going to review your case
in just eight clicks also they have
4,000 support staff that can help you
too which is just amazing to think about
and in terms of price well you only pay
them if you win there's no upfront fee
so if you're injured and you want to
join the over three million people that
call them every year you can submit a
claim at www. forthepeople.com
lcam or by dialing pound law that's
pound 529 on your phone next we cross
state lines to Michigan where a
motorcycle is jumped into the kalamazo
river to flee from
officers we're going down to the river
stop he's in the river so I'm going to
get across to uh the old Arcadia ALS it
happened on New Year's Day in Kalamazoo
Michigan according to officials officers
initiated a traffic stop on the
motorcycle but instead the motorcyclist
fled from police at one point the
motorcycle was experiencing mechanical
issues which prompted the chase to go on
foot body camera video captures the
moments the officer catches up to the
motorcyclist who jumped into the river
to avoid arrest
stop he's in the river so I'm going get
across to uh the old Arcadia
ALS
get out of the
water he's in the middle of the river
right now looks like he's kind of giving
up he's just kind of walking in the
river
you're going to go to jail anyway dude
give
up we're going to need the squad he's
trying to swim down the river he's
probably going to get hypothermic
soon he's heading
north if we can get someone up to the uh
bridge on Patterson and that uh park for
S par
versus the park uh just adjacent to
those new buildings off of Harrison
we definitely need the squad out here I
think he's having trouble swimming he's
going
underwater then the chase turns into
tragedy if anybody has a rope or
anything we can throw to him we going to
need it he looks like he's drowning come
out here
now you're going to die in there dude
come
on dude just walk over here come on
we're going to take you anyway
you are going to ground get
out I think
that use the current keep doggy
paddling come over here we're moving
Northbound in the river it's going to be
north of Michigan between the bridge on
Michigan and
Patterson
get hey he's
[Applause]
[Music]
under he's underwater we have to jump in
and get him he's he's right here right
in front of this
tree he's he's floating too fast that
way
he's right by that he's right by that
green
box I can't see him
anymore I don't see
[Applause]
him
we
got where is he
at we don't see him we don't see him we
cannot see him in a shocking twist the
motorcyclist disappears into the river
and never resurface it's unclear who the
suspect was authorities say they're
still working to confirm his identity
and lastly we head down south to Florida
where a tick tock challenge ends in the
arrest of two teens it happened on
December 19th in valua County Florida
when deputies spotted a Kia Soul minutes
after it was reported stolen going give
me the channel it's going to be uh the
pending signal 10 POA Charlie gol here
26 Tallwood and corland occupied white
nail driver so normal speed it's covered
in mud on the right side yeah
[Music]
confir corland Puerto Rico ASR the call
said the window was busted out the right
rear window is gone on this car and
there's a gun in the glove box and he's
all right we're going signal
12 I got 12 that for on corland
uh I'm slowing down but he's going to be
coming up the lam here in a second two
occupants male and female I believe but
white
M I lost visual uh I think he's still
probably going to be heading Northland
cour
though silver keia soul got on both
sides back right side windows busted out
uh I don't know where it's at though man
shortly after the body cam cuts to the
deputy approaching the vehicle which
seems to be stuck in a marsh but was
abandoned
you the video then cuts to the teens
approaching the deputies and they were
later cuffed officials say the two were
taking part in What's called the Kia
challenge a dangerous social media Trend
which shows users how to steal certain
Kia and Hyundai models using items such
as a USB connector and a screwdriver
officials say the teen driver was later
connected to several similar cases in
belua County authorities believe the
teens were doing the trend in an attempt
to get likes on social media reporting
for long crime I'm Elizabeth Milner